huntington disease is an inherited  neurodegenerative disorder where the  movement or motor control is abrogated  functional abilities movement motor  control and cognitive abilities are  disrupted in this disease  the medium spiny neurons are degenerated  and the age of onset is 30 to 50 and it  is inherited in nature we have a bipedal  motor gate which is disrupted in this  disease  the basal ganglia inhibits involuntary  movement and the medium spiny neurons  are the key players in this in  huntington disease these neurons are  degenerated  this particular disease is associated  with protein folding related and protein  aggregation related problems the  pathology involves  overall degeneration of the brain and  there could be dystonia of the muscle  that means decrease in muscle tone  overall there is no treatment of this  disease but  there are medications which can treat  the symptoms subscribe for more